okay so we've talked about the NRA's
reaction to the Las Vegas mass shooting
we've talked about extremists cleric Pat
Robertson's reaction to the Las Vegas
shooting what about a country musician
the Josh Abbott band is a country music
act and not surprisingly after the
biggest mass shooting in American
history in Las Vegas over the weekend
the band posted a message of thoughts
for the victims on Twitter not at all
surprising but it went further the
guitarist for the Josh Abbott band is
Caleb keator and he went further and he
pointed out that the incident has
fundamentally changed his mind about gun
control he posted to social media I've
been a proponent of the Second Amendment
my entire life until the events of last
night I cannot express how wrong I was
we actually have members of our crew
with concealed handgun licenses and
legal firearms on the bus they were
useless we couldn't touch them for fear
police might think we were part of the
massacre and shoot us a small group or
one man laid waste to a city with
dedicated fearless police officers
desperately trying to help because of
access to an insane amount of firepower
we need gun control right now
my biggest regret is that I stubbornly
didn't realize it until my brothers on
the road and myself were threatened by
it
we are unbelievably fortunate to not be
AB among the number of victims killed or
seriously wounded by this maniac first
of all I'm glad he spoke up because if
you're in the country music world there
is risk to taking a position like this
country music fans don't take kindly
often to anything other than standard
right wing a pro-gun apologia look at
the blacklisting on endless radio
stations of the Dixie Chicks when they
spoke out during george w bush's
invasion of iraq they spoke out against
that many in the country community
including endless country music stations
blacklisted them just one example now as
far as the logistics of what caleb is
saying here he makes the point i've been
making for years in a general sense it's
easy to say oh good guys with guns
stopped the
guys with guns think about the
situations though because it's not that
simple there's a shooting going on and
police show up and they see people with
guns
you think they'll easily identify in the
chaos who are the good people versus the
bad people with the guns and to go even
even further
how do multiple good guys with guns
properly identify who is actually the
shooter amidst the chaos without
accidentally shooting each other and a
great example of this it's a tragic
example is the Aurora Colorado movie
theater shooting when we heard from so
many gun advocates if the movie theater
hadn't been a gun-free zone good guys
with guns could have been armed and when
the Aurora shooter started shooting they
the good guys with guns could have shot
back you're telling me that in a
darkened movie theater where the sound
of the of the shots being fired would be
reverberating in an absolutely insane
and headache-inducing way that you'd be
able to figure out what the direction of
fire was and of course who the bad guy
with the gun is if all of a sudden ten
people take out handguns it's absolutely
ridiculous in this particular case in
Vegas by the way the shooter was thirty
two floors up and four or five hundred
yards away anyone firing from the ground
how are you gonna hit the suspect up on
the 32nd floor without more likely
risking hurting other civilians so these
are fantasies so clearly on the
specifics I agree with Caleb keator but
my concern is that it took something
personal happening to him for him to
change his mind shouldn't we all be able
to imagine what it might be like to be
in that situation and come to the same
conclusions that Caleb came to I feel
like I am right like I came to the same
conclusions as Caleb without being in
the situation he was in
why does it take some people's
involvement personally in an incident
like this to realize hey you know what
my view doesn't make sense I need to
rethink my views that's really what bums
me out because it really shouldn't take
being personally involved to say hey you
know what we need some of these
common-sense gun safety rules and laws
even if it wouldn't have prevented this
particular incident what argument
remains against 100% totally universal
background checks for example so
thing that even after Sandy Hook with 80
or 85 percent support our legislators
failed to pass that's the part that bums
me out but I'm still glad that Caleb
keator came to these conclusions send me
your thoughts I'm on twitter at the
Pakman the show is on twitter at david
pakman show quick break back with plenty
more